as c.s lewis said  hardships often prepare ordinary people  for an extraordinary destiny  people look at their past to decide who  they are people look at their path to  decide who they can be but the problem  is oftentimes people mistake  difficulties  suffering  pain  for being bad being less than being  broken and it erodes their sense of  self-esteem it erodes their sense of  self-worth  but nothing could be more opposite from  the truth because in reality no matter  what you've gone through no matter how  hard it was all of it was shaping you  into the person that you can become the  hardships the difficulties the pain the  suffering all of that makes you tougher  it is literally in the difficulties that  you begin to find just how much you're  capable of it's in the suffering that  you find out how resilient you are it's  in the pain that you can rise up and get  tough